Probiotics - they’re great for your gut,
but what else are they good for?
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and it seems
like probiotics are all the health rage lately.
If you’re not familiar, probiotics are microorganisms,
like bacteria and yeast, that replenish all
the good flora in your gut - and help aid
your body in digestion.
Every day we discover new benefits of probiotics,
so if you’re not yet convinced of all the
wonderful things they can do for your health
- then here are a couple more.
A new study in PLOS ONE finds that eating
probiotics for just a month - can help diminish
the accumulation of fat in your liver.
Now before you get TOO excited, this study
was done on rats - so it’s not totally clear
how this translates to humans, but in any
case, it’s a good step towards the fight
against Non-Alcoholic Fatty Liver Disease.
NAFLD is a build-up of fat in the liver that’s
not caused by alcohol, and it’s closely
related to obesity and diabetes.
It’s a fairly common disease that most people
don’t even know they have, but in more extreme
cases, it can lead to scarring of the liver,
and liver failure.
For their study, researchers administered
3 different strains of probiotics to obese
rats, for 30 days - and found that it significantly
reduced the amount of fat buildup in the liver,
compared to rats that were fed a placebo.
Researchers say this doesn’t mean that probiotics
can cure liver disease, but it does demonstrate
their anti-inflammatory properties.
And it supports the idea that our intestinal
bacteria can directly influence our liver
metabolism.
This goes hand in hand with another study,
published this week in Hypertension, which
finds that regular probiotic intake can actually
improve your blood pressure.
Researchers analyzed 9 different studies,
and found that consuming at least a billion
CFUs of probiotics daily - which is about
how much you’d find in a supplement capsule
- lowered systolic blood pressure in patients
by around 3.5 points, and diastolic blood
pressure by about 2.5 points.
Not a massive difference, but the effect is
more pronounced in people with elevated blood
pressure levels, of at least 130/85.
It’s also worth noting that probiotics with
multiple strains of bacteria are more effective
than those with just a single strain.
But no matter what kind you take, they do
have to be consumed for at least 8 weeks in
order to see the positive effects.
Researchers believe that while probiotics
don’t directly influence someone’s blood
pressure - they do have other positive effects
on the body, that can lead to lower blood
pressure.
They improve your cholesterol, they reduce
blood glucose levels, and they help regulate
the hormone system responsible for regulating
blood pressure.
So go ahead - eat all the yogurt you want!
And if you hate yogurt, let us know your preferred
method of getting your daily probiotics.
Just leave em in the comments below, and as
always - thank you guys for watching!